ich kenne ja schon puls wenn ich das
sehe das jetzt irgendwelche
steinzeitmenschen uns dem westen die
bedingungen diktieren es ist irgendwie
die verkehrte welt also der taliban man
sagt wenn ihr nicht hier verschwunden
seit heute in einer woche übrigens die
uhr tickt dann gibt es eine reaktion
wenn man das einmal genau analysiert was
soll denn so eine reaktion sein der wird
dann wahrscheinlich kein brief schreiben
sondern selbstmordattentäter schicken
das ist eine ganz klare kriegs ich würde
sogar sagen drohung nicht nur erklärung
mit einem ganz klaren ultimatum von
einem verbrecher von einem terroristen
ein terrorist diktiert der westlichen
welt die bedingungen das ist der stand
am heutigen tag das ist nicht nur
bedenklich dass es bedrohlich und ich
bin sehr gespannt was die staatschefs
als antwort formulieren und ich habe so
sorge und angst dass es wieder ein dahin
betteln wird bitte bitte taliban man
gibt uns mehr zeit um unsere leute
herauszuholen da wird er einmal kurz
lachen und sagen dann zahlt dafür und
wir hängen so was die westliche welt mit
unseren werten für die menschen soldaten
in afghanistan gestorben sind hängen wir
jetzt sozusagen an der gunst eines
mannes aus einem anderen zeitalter der
für einen verbrecher regime steht der
für einen terroristen eine terroristen
organisation steht der verein system
steht dass frauen unterdrückt menschen
steinigt tötet wenn sie sich nicht an
die regeln halten das ist der tiefpunkt
der letzten 20 jahre
[Musik]